point numéro 1 euh standard P ils sont
très gentils mais enfin c'est deux types
en France ça va alors pour juger pour
juger de l'avenir de notre modèle
économique et social ça me paraît un peu
court bon une fois que j'ai dit ça non
mais parce que c'est très important
parce que moi je vais vous dire Monsieur
moi je travaille à un dossier de mise en
cause judiciaire des agences de notation
pour les erreurs gigantesque qu'elles
ont fait quand elles nous ont dit qu'un
certain nombre de paquets de subprimes à
l'époque était 3A oui c'est vrai qu'ell
n'ont rien vu à l'époque vous êtes
engagé dans un combat Judici ouioui
absolument je vous dire
pourquois tout seul j'ai besoin de
personne vous savez je suis un vieil
avocat rompu bon je vais dire pourquoi
c'est très grave c'est très grave parce
que en 2008 le monde a fait
sombrer c'est la seule activité qui peut
se permettre de se tromper à ce point
sans aucune responsabilité et vous savez
pourquoi il y a pas de responsabilité
parce qu'il y a une loi américaine qui
les protège en considérant qu'il ne faut
qu'émettent une opinion c'est loi de la
presse mais pas en France pas en France
et donc j'ai décidé je suis pas membre
du gouvernement ça n'engage pas mon pays
j'ai décidé de déposer ce dossier
maintenant sur la réalité des tribunaux
français auprès des tribunaux français
parce que parce que la loi sur la presse
ne s'applique pas en France lo
américaine d'accord qu'est-ce que vous
voulez au bout du bout l'interdiction
l'interdiction non les dommagesintérêt
pour les dégradations qu'elles ont
produit elles ont pendant des années
garanties garanti que tout ce fa y
compris la MAN Brothers je rappelle à 8
semaines 8 semaines du crche 3A triple A
allez-y investissez non mais c'est un
vraiemblable alors oui on se souvient de
le RERS de
Enron sont complètement planté
vou auourd'hui des dommages et inérêt
mais je pense que ceux qui ont subi des
des dommages doivent avoir dommages inér
Dom centaines de milliardsou mais il y a
un vieux principe du Code civil qui est
l'article
1382 qui dit que tout fait qui a causé à
autrui un préjudice oblige celui par l'
faut duquel il est arrivé à le réparer
je demande donc qu'il y a un expert
international qui soit nommé pour
regarder